welcome to this video playing tiger
Petrosian okay from from finland i am
from finland yeah probably there are not
so many of the houses the name in them
oops sick Marco manninen Michael Mullen
maybe step brother of hannah manninen
Moloch cheat ski champion okay let's see
um we have this taraji I i recently had
the squid with black in one of my blitz
games should be 70 this all a success
what is usually played yeah I am need to
play it by ear I don't don't don't know
it too well you will play Bishop d6 I
need to probably play this move anyway
at some point so let's let's do it okay
the question is short or long castles
well now if he castles long have 95
gaining the bishops okay all I are able
to okay wait wait wait he could play the
check and play no yeah kick let's do it
he could play the check and play Queenie
five theoretically speaking with that I
didn't okay well it's this is some
at least something okay he wants to get
rid of one of the bishops immediately
no right I need some I need some play on
the on the queenside maybe a 500k for
this kind of move black actually can try
to go for g5g five G for this would be a
valid plan ok well now g5 I probably
just take some it's not so easy 22
they're pretty to look at it too of
course could could try the head rock
digital probably Cooper Queen g5 as a
move Queen g5 rook f2 by this is a this
is a weird line okay let's let's wait
what is doing look it to quit g5 rook f2
this is really working king of 294 check
the idea and rogue f1 f2 actually covers
the night so after yeah well what a
stupid line he will play and it's
probably a completely different move of
course a general issue on that needs to
be mentioned um office his long castles
is that it's um yeah it's always less
secure in comparison to 22 short
canceling situation because it's just
two pawns and this is simply a less
reliable shelter than three pawns
so what's it's a bit tricky sometimes
Kim Ticketek the light now maybe maybe
Queen Queen their form and I've Queen a
phone but this is also a bit of a self
pen maybe just look everyone and his
Pippen himself what problem is that f5
natural move phones not working due to
Bishop takes c6 check
yeah he can go night to see Five yeah
but I'll go here it's not it's not like
that that the bishop is so great but
what I want to do is Bishop back to f1
keep keeping the King young I thought c3
I cannot to do this ok ok I see I
probably here I don't I need to get out
of the pin that's this is necessary and
then what I wanted to do with all this
is with this Bishop transfer getting a
additional piece to secure the king but
also I wanted to prepare be form yeah
this is interesting now should I play
yeah I should don't want to exchange
Quincy ff3 nice got a form of three is
got 95 f 194 yes so let's let's push
this away maybe if maybe I should have
played c3 first maybe
yeah still it's not obvious what you
should do now 95 I play ac3 and before e
6 hanging with check tonight c5 I
probably have other interesting options
through k3 for example look III c 3
yeah I didn't see that at all pool let's
see maybe here just the rook Wow a
techie this is attacking the night he
might play Nagi wait wait 95 is a tricky
move okay okay come on let's stop this
nonsense get the Queen's off now this is
probably not bad at all I mean takes
rook takes I'm only 736 sorry and here
yeah there's c3 and before simple simple
simple approach or o'keefe I froakie 5
Roxy rookie 5 it's not helping okay no
here mmm Bishop c4 now is cut e5 okay
let's get rid of one look this is
probably a good idea Fisher oh wait what
months now what is it doing now rook e8
okay this way this is a bit passive
though okay i need the king my king
needs to blame
where'd you go probably to f3 yeah I
want to control you five you for now
it's a mistake that's a mistake it gives
me deform and much the much more active
position okay overlooked 9 f8 bad timing
yeah that was stupid ah that's bad bad
bad timing check
yeah I probably cannot win I don't I
don't think so c5 and Bishop c4 time
morning I want to go to a 2 2 GA chances
of course the IDM black for effects on
time and you can see that you are sooo
long time yeah be sure to g8 and taking
h7s size intention and should win really
yeah this is winning now but played have
probably played this cletas in not in
the most accurate way well this this is
winning I'm getting the h-bond so I'd
say something like this this is possible
impossible to stop relief or only with
the serious material losses but I still
made made a bad mistake here this is
this is nonsense I need to play a better
movie i can i can play probably play G 4
I can go to hear again go at any time
this is more precise I need to be sure
that he cannot easily go to e6 g4 g6
Bishop c4 this is how I must play that
and this is very good now this is very
good I'm eyeing those important points
and here black has every porn on light
squares and this I don't think this is
defensible
it looks very bad for example 9 f 6 for
example a g5 I can go g5 let's check
let's check out new flea yeah he's got
this one okay so g5 is not on what
should i do money i can i can play
something like that and still those
pawns are target's down light is much
better not sure if it's winning not so
sure okay well thanks for watching